DOCTOR STRANGE
Every night...
...I dream the same dream.
And then...
[Gasping]
...the nightmare begins.
DOCTOR STRANGE
I did what I had to do...
...to protect our world.
WONG
You cannot control everything, Strange.
You opened a doorway
between universes,
and we don't know who or
what will walk through it.
DOCTOR STRANGE
Wanda.
What do you know about the Multiverse?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Vis had his theories.
He believed it was dangerous.
DOCTOR STRANGE
He was right.
♪♪
MORDO
I'm sorry, Stephen.
Your desecration of reality...
...will not go unpunished.
MYSTERY VOICE
We should tell him the truth.
♪♪
[Screaming]
SINISTER STRANGE
Things just got out of hand.
♪♪
SCARLET WITCH
You break the rules...
AMERICA CHAVEZ
Look out!
SCARLET WITCH
...and become the hero.
I do it and I become the enemy.
♪♪
That doesn't seem fair.
WONG
Strange!
♪♪